Deep in tropical jungles life floating kingdoms ruled by beautiful and
deadly masters. They're sort of the high elves of the ant kingdoms,
talented architects, the create castles and city States,
but they are also fierce and expansionist warriors.
And that kingdoms are ensnared in a never ending war for survival.
It Koffler Weaver ads.
[Inaudible].
Oh, it Koffler weavers walk on long legs have slender bodies and large eyes,
which make them look pretty cute.
Although they're strong mandibles and the ability to shoot acid also make them
pretty good at Kenning.
But more on that later that colonies usually have two to three
worker classes that vary dramatically in size majors, minors,
and sometimes even tiny minim workers,
depending on location and species.
They vary in color from dark Brown to Emerald grain other than their
fancy Lokes.
What makes weavers special is that they're in the kingdom building business.
They like to build at pretty much all Heights, starting in shrubs,
a few centerpieces above the ground and up to 10 meters in the tree canopy,
but they're not satisfied with ruling. Just one plot.
We've weavers we'll look for twigs,
all the honors that bridge the gap to other trees and expand to every plant.
They can reach this way.
Codon is spread upwards and sideways through the tree tops,
the largest Weaver and kingdoms.
We know of occupy up to 1,600 square meters
around four basketball courts,
a lot of ground to cover for tiny ants and impossibly hard to control.
So we've ants construct dozens of nests scattered all over their territory,
outposts to defend the kingdom tubes or balls made from leaves and ghostly silk
sheets.
These masterpieces of and architecture are created by the Weaver
majors, the larger worker ants,
which are responsible for the more dangerous jobs like fighting foraging and
nest construction. To start a new nest,
a major tries to band different leaves in her surroundings into a tube.
If one of the leaves is flexible enough,
more workers will arrive to help chains of workers pull the Leaf's edges
together,
or reach across gaps and grab distant leaves to add them to the construction
while the bending and pulling is going on.
Other workers carry larvae from the closest nest to the construction site.
Usually ant larvae spend themselves a cocoon to protect themselves,
but the and larvae give all of their soak to the colony as building material.
So when the workers tapped the love, his heads on the leaf,
they released their sticky thread like tiny, cute glue guns, this way,
the workers, so the bent leaf onto itself. So it won't unfold anymore.
This creates a central chamber that's used as the basis for up to 300 more
leaves that are wound around it together.
They form little pockets and act as additional rooms for the new outpost to
make it even more cozy.
Miner workers use the larvae to weave additional floors and chambers nests are
usually constructed as barracks on the territory's borders or a storage for
brood and food supplies. This way,
the ants don't need to cross vast distances to the headquarters,
but have soldiers close to any potential point of conflict apart from one
special nest in the middle of the network,
which is reserved for the queen and her guards here,
she produces hundreds of eggs a day,
which get transferred to suitable nests with brood chambers.
So a colony is a network of little castles and moats connected by suspension.
Bridges made from leaves,
the honors and Twix and establish colony easily has half a
million individuals that need to be fed. Fortunately,
we've answered evolve to have very close and beneficial relationships with their
hosts, shrubs and trees.
The tree gives the answer home and access to sweet SAP to drink,
but maybe even more importantly,
it allows them to cultivate cattle like aphids or caterpillars that produce
honeydew for them. This would usually hurt a tree,
but these insects belong to a small group of VIP's only a few
selected neighbors and the aunt's cattle are allowed on the fruit tree,
many other insects and even larger herbivores or scat off or even
killed and eaten. So most cases,
the tree only has to tolerate acceptable levels of damage while being protected
from more dangerous pasts,
the Weaver ant kingdom could be an ant paradise. If there wasn't competition,
mostly from other kingdoms, slink, medieval humans,
every queen seeks to conquer others and make their land. Their own controlling.
Fertile land is the key to survive in the jungle.
And if a kingdom loses too much of,
as it shrinks and is overrun or starves to death,
so expanding and defending their borders is critical to keep the colony alive.
When a kingdom invades another,
it first gathered an army of a few thousand majors who make their way towards
the opposing colony.
The goal is to steal a bit of territory and take it over defending weave
patrols, quickly, spot the invaders and immediately release an alarm pheromone,
some rush to the front,
to defend while others rushed to the closest outposts for help marking their
route with pheromones. Whenever they meet other sisters,
they jerked their bodies as if in a fight to signal them,
to follow the pheromone trail to the frontline at the site of battle
majors from both parties, raise their bodies,
circle each other with mandibles open and try to seize their opponents.
If an ant gets a hold of her opponent,
the victim is pulled into a group of allied majors and pinned down
the ants. Then rip the victim apart,
clipping off antennae and legs and slicing open thereafter modes
to slow down the advance of the attackers.
The defending majors squirt formic acid over the battlefield to chemically Berg,
their targets.
This is soon answered in the same way by the attackers in the chaotic battle.
Both parties lose countless fighters on the increasingly acidic battlefield.
After a few minutes,
the backup from the outposts arrive in the time window for a successful attack,
slowly closes.
This is when the battle turns the defenders slowly.
Push-back the attack party. In the end,
the attackers can't keep up and have to retreat for both parties.
It was a costly battle.
Thousands of corpses lie piled up on the ground under the battlefield,
and many ants are severely injured. The defending colonies,
nests and bruise are safe though.
The attacker's attempt to steal new valuable territory has failed for today.
They'll try again soon,
but the kingdom will be ready for the high ants of the floating
kingdoms. War is nothing special.
It's just a fact of life because as we know,
empires never ever have enough and the Weaver ants are ready to
fight.
This video is part three of a series that was developed with the support of
curiosity stream,
a subscription streaming service with thousands of documentaries and non-fiction
titles.
Curiosity stream was founded by the same people who started the discovery
channel. So it's all about documentaries on science, nature, history technology,
and pretty much any other topic of interest you can think of if you're the same
as us and love to learn things while watching fun videos. This is for you.
For example,
David Attenborough is and mountain the perfect sequel to this video to let you
stay in the ant around for a little longer,
you can watch thousands of documentaries and nonfiction TV shows on all
streaming devices for only $2 99 per month.
And there's a special treat for coats cause out viewers,
by clicking the link in the inbox and using the code cuts,
[inaudible] aren't you get 25% off your annual plan.
That means it's just $14 and 99 cents for the entire year.
Thanks to our friends at CuriosityStream for supporting us in making ambitious
and beautiful projects like this video happen.
Stay antsy for part four and visit curiosity stream.com/
[inaudible] to claim your discount. Thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].